now let me introduce the distinguished
ambassador he was born in nineteen forty
four and he joined the Foreign Service
in 1966 at the age of 22 and he served
in Indian missions from nineteen sixty
eight to nineteen eighty four in Moscow
san francisco in dhaka and also in the
Ministry of External Affairs has also
been interestingly enough secretary to
the atomic energy commission of india in
july 1984 to December 1985 he was joint
secretary in the Ministry of External
Affairs he was also then thereafter
joint secretary to the Prime Minister
from 1986 to July 1991 responsible for
Foreign Affairs defense science and
technology so he is very appropriate
that he gives us the keynote address he
was ambassador to Mexico ambassador to
russian federation ambassador to germany
High Commissioner to the UK and so he
has a wide range of diplomatic
experience he has also participated in
several summit meetings in the United
Nations Commonwealth non-aligned
movement sick nation five continent
peace initiative you name it he has been
at it all so he's married and as they
have one daughter I don't know that she
is going to yell or not but if she's not
she should be but well with these words
of welcome I would request ambassador
send to deliver his keynote address
thank you very much professor
sreenivasan for your warm words of
introduction and for your insights it's
and I would like to add the outside I
would like to congratulate professor
srini Watson who has been honored with a
very high award from the President of
India just recently on the occasion of
our our republic day so I mean I'm happy
to see such a distinguished audience
people familiar faces we know because
ambassador Rick end of Earth master
Jessie Shafer our consul general neelam
day oh and of course mr. Harmon choksi
up there good to see you and wish you a
very good morning and highly privileged
to have been given this opportunity to
speak at this venerable institution of
iconic stretcher I'm sorry that my
daughter has not been to hear she went
to another place called you and earlier
she was in clermont small yeah but Sir
and but she missed you but it's not too
late and I congratulate Yale University
and taking this timely initiative in
organizing symposia and i would like to
especially appreciate the work which has
been done by dr. george joseph and all
his colleagues including Barbara Papa
koda and I thank you for your arranging
this event first very briefly I
to say that you know according to
conventional wisdom that the
relationship in in between India and the
United States was basically it was bad
during the time of the Cold War and
after the fall of Berlin Wall and the
collapse of the Soviet Union the wisdom
the given wisdom is that things improved
and allowed a natural partnership to
evolve sounds very logical but ants
widely believed but i think it's untrue
the reality is that our relationship was
good at times it was bad at times but
was indifferent for long periods of time
it had good beginnings and right at the
time of and we all in india we all
remember the invaluable support strong
sentiments of support which is expressed
by President Roosevelt and other very
prominent Americans for independence
movement our Constitution was deeply
influenced by the US Constitution are at
that time you don't have very strong IPR
regulations but it you know are we we
had our bill of right i mean the bill of
rights was almost completely
incorporated in our what's known as a
fundamental rights and I new Indian
Constitution and so the US influence was
great even though I'd say that dr.
Ambedkar made the mistake of not
studying at here and he was of all
places in Columbia and it's not oh well
with near whose first visit there
despite his remark that you know once
you never visit the United States for
the first time it's a it was successful
with it he got on pretty well with
President Eisenhower and particularly
when mr. Krishna Menon and John Foster
Dulles was not there in that room but
and and Eisenhower's won't visit
was highly successful he was greeted
with very great enthusiasm wherever he
went and the relationship of course
reaches lows during the time of Nixon
Bangladesh and also during the Carter
presidency but they were revived during
the Reagan years and it was in fact we
saw the longest period of what I would
call a benign neglect it was after the
Cold War period for a long time and Nan
neglect on both sides I was saying and
before it was there was a jolt given by
the 1998 nuclear test by India and of
course after that we had this incident
known as a kargil conflict and and
thereafter a very historic visit made by
President Clinton to India of course
first lady then first lady hillary
clinton beat him to it because he went
there earlier in own capacity as first
lady but that was a truly historic
landmark in a relationship and this
relationship gained unprecedented
heights since the inception of the Bush
administration and since then it's been
accelerating very rapidly and is being
transformed into truly strategic
partnership this transformation ladies
and gentlemen is not on the basis of any
single strategic goal but it is dynamic
and multifaceted and the changes are
profound and palpable and I'm
manifesting themselves in different
areas I just give you a broad picture of
some developments and just to give you
an idea i'll just list it restrict
myself to initiatives which have been
taken just in the last two years to give
you a flavor of the range and the extent
of the transformation of this
relationship we there was a process
known as the next steps in strategic
partnership
or the NSS be as it's called which was
initiated by President Bush and Prime
Minister watch by in january 2004 it was
rapidly the process was completed with
stage two and three being dovetailed and
by completed by june two thousand five
just on the eve of Prime Minister
Manmohan Singh's visit to India and this
envisage cooperation in civil nuclear
energy civilian use of space and also
high technologies dual-use technologies
and in missile defense the high
technology cooperation group has been
energized and it's dealing with issues
concentrating focusing right now on
biotechnology nanotechnology of course
information communication technology and
it's added on defense technologies in
the field of defense we had in June
again again 2005 also the conclusion of
a landmark agreement atenea program
perspective of cooperation in the field
of defense which included also
cooperation and collaboration in defence
procurement and production the and also
there's been another feature which is
virtually I mean hardly a month goes by
without some exercise with the other
taking place between our Navy's Army's
Air Forces Special Forces in various
different areas and that has given a lot
of confidence and built up mutual trust
and respect for each other's
capabilities trade is growing in both
directions and and I would like to say
that
there is a imbalance into at least in
terms of trading goods which needs to be
corrected and so it's been mined ever to
try to promote US exports to india as
actively or aggressively as i try to
promote indian exports in the united
states and and i'm glad that US exports
windia are growing faster than india and
exports to the united states the same is
happening the field of investments I
remember when I was in London and I
first reach London in 2004 sorry in 2002
I was considered rather eccentric you
know because when people give me a very
patient listening when I told them that
look you shortly have there'll be a time
when Indian investments in the united
kingdom would equal british investments
in india but now that's not only come
true but actually indian investments in
the united kingdom exceed british
investments in india and in fact last
year was the first year and this is a
worrisome development but i mentioning
to you because for the first year the
first time that investments into india
by india abroad exceeded investments in
our country but that is the general
direction which we are headed and that's
a hilly trend we have an economic
dialogue which has been revitalized and
which also resulted in the setting up of
a ce o--'s forum which is provided very
valuable inputs we have embarked on a
knowledge initiative in the field of
Agriculture which brings in universities
research institutions corporate America
corporate India and this agricultural
knowledge initiative you backed it with
funding of over 100 million dollars for
the next three years
and this is why tightly important for us
because this is an area where the Indian
economy has not done as well as it
should have done and we can do much
better and we hope that this initiative
will yield tangible benefits and in fact
we hope that will become result in a
second Green Revolution in India by
increasing productivity cutting down
shortages and maximizing the
increasingly rather rapidly the income
to farmers by processing and packaging
of agricultural produce energy is
another very critical area where we just
in the last two years this is one area
we will launch the dialogue of course
the most visible has been the civil
nuclear initiative which is widely
important both in terms of symbolism and
substance but it's not being restricted
to the nuclear cooperation sense of it's
been broader because it's included
collaboration or exchanges in the field
of oil and gas they feel the power field
of coal where we've joined what's known
as a future gen project for clean coal
technologies and also in energy
efficiency and new and renewable forms
veggie and I mentioned this initiative
in particular because i think that the
greatest challenge which india is going
to face is infrastructure in general but
most specifically where we are the most
vulnerable is in the area of energy and
water scarcity and the need to address
these two issues which are actually
interlinked we have taken several other
initiatives is just to give you another
example an Open Skies agreement
was signed and distant dream remain on
paper and since then in the last few
months you've seen three American US
airlines commencing direct nonstop
flights to India they'll be followed by
several more and this trend is going to
continue and both in terms of passenger
traffic and cargo traffic we have
launched trade policy forum which is
headed by our commerce and industry
minister and the USTR Susan Schwab in
fact soon Schwab is right now even as I
speak in and tele this meeting is taking
place the fourth meeting of this forum
in the US has to such forums to other
such forums one with the European Union
and one with China and how's the third
third such forum and I expect I hope
what I'm going to say is not i think
that the end of it they're going to
announce or they have all I think
announced today or they'll announce
tomorrow the setting up of a private
sector advisory group to provide inputs
to this trade policy forum cooperation
in maritime security of course
prevention of privacy piracy rather
pollution search and rescue missions
dealing with emergent situations that's
underway it's we've we have an agreement
and we're implementing that we had a
science and technology agreement which
is languishing for ten years ten long
years we focused on that and within a
couple of months or so we got that
agreement finalized and we followed that
up again with setting up a science
technology fund to promote to promote
certain projects which are amenable to
industrial application and backed it up
with significant funding a number of
other initiatives have been taken by us
and within the last two years
have global implications in the field of
democracy for instance promotion of
democracy it was natural that the UN
democracy fund was launched by president
bush and Prime Minister Manmohan Singh
at the united nations in the presence of
heads of state and government or both
old democracies and new democracies and
what we call democracies in transition
we are active participants in the
coalition of democracies and we also
decided both of us simultaneously to
join the Governing Board of the Budapest
based institution which is for
democracies and democracies in
transition our cooperation of course in
the field of in the area of combating
international terrorism that preceded
911 it's acquired new momentum
thereafter and we are we have a shared
interest a very strong shared interest
in preventing proliferation of weapons
of mass destruction and our worst case
national security nightmare would be a
combination of the two that's nuclear
terrorism after the tsunami you know
that we as a country though we were hit
by the tsunami of what 1,400 miles of
our coastline was affected but we be
where we did not receive aid we in
rather joined in the in a very active
program to assist those countries who
were affected in our neighborhood
particularly sri lanka and maldives and
and at that time i remember the the
spontaneous support we got from the
front people of the United States and
the solidarity which was
very heartwarming and the visit to the
embassy we're privileged to receive
President Bush Senior and President
Clinton and and of course the current
president bush and the first lady Laura
Bush then strike me at that time that
all these the current and the two former
presidents were all from Yale it did
striking at that time but now it just
happens to me so but we didn't we had a
cooperation a core group which is set up
which is consisting of the United States
India and be included Japan and the
Australian this in this venture but to
be followed that up by us-india desires
disaster response initiative which is
working out quite well similarly we have
taken initiatives in combating hiv/aids
and other pandemics like the avian flu
very shortly for the first international
conference on avian flu will be held in
intelli and in the field of environment
and number of other areas so this will
just give you just a flavor of as i said
the extent of it some of the initiatives
which are just taken in the last two
years and this is just some of them
there are others but while there are
several others i've just like to briefly
touch on to other one other subject
that's cooperation in the field of
education I've attached very high
importance to this area of our
cooperation very high priority because
there's much talk about the what we call
the Democrat and demographic dividend
you know because with more than half our
population below the age of 25
and so you know when we add the the
general theory is that with growing
numbers of both will be having growing
numbers of both producers as and
consumers in India at the time when
there'd be a large number of increasing
number of pensioners not only in the
West but in Japan China and elsewhere
but I believe in I believe very strongly
that much of this in fact will not be
achieved unless we do something and we
take some radical steps to address the
problem of the lack of adequate
educational facilities particularly
starting with from primary school and
mid school level and but also in the
field of higher education and we will
have to without investments and without
concerted efforts on an emergency
footing I do not think that we will be
able to realize the advantages or or
realize what is this I refer to as the
demographic dividend and I would like to
say in this context that there is we
encourage that there have been some some
cooperation already taken place like
there's means of cooperation in on
distance education the group of us in
universities and I'm also glad that just
in the last two years we're just talking
to the two year perspective as compared
to the past the number of visits by
university presidents Provost's another
have others have more than quadrupled
and i hope this 10 trend will be
maintained as also other trends like the
numbers of senators and congressmen
visiting India has last two years also
has quadrupled in fact a little bit more
than that it's about increased by 450
percent number of CEOs of major
companies visiting India
much more visits become much more
focused but the numbers of us also have
more than tripled and these developments
just give you some idea of the new
direction the new content and momentum
of the evolution of the strategic
partnership which as Professor
sreenivasan rightly pointed out is a
mutual benefit to the to India and the
United States and it also has a profound
positive impact in a global perspective
with regard to the prospects for future
very briefly a little bit of crystal
ball gazing first much has changed in
the world you had the end of the Cold
War but the emergence of new threats the
u.s. is unquestioned and the by any by
any criteria the world's only superpower
but still even then the u.s. cannot on
its own handle the problems which I
refer to the problems which are new
problems that show emerged the new
challenges and threats which have
emerged in post-cold war era era so it
is not a unipolar world and I don't
think it will be in a polar the second
is that India is also changing sometimes
we confuse many people including
ourselves by some developments we
sometimes take two steps forward one
step backwards but basically we are
moving ahead in the right direction and
we are no longer just the world's
biggest democracy the largest democracy
but the world's fastest-growing
democracy and I believe that unless we
really make a mess of things it's it's
inevitable let's question of when and
not a question of if
we will emerge as one of the world's
three largest economies the third factor
is that India's growth economic growth
is not threatening the interest of
others regionally or in a global
perspective foreign trade will play a
much greater role and this will be a
positive factor in sense of our
integration to the global economy but
our growth will be propelled not so much
by exports but by domestic demand
fourthly our economic growth has
demonstrated that development and
democracy are not just compatible people
thought that they are not compatible but
we have demonstrated that they are not
just compatible but inextricably linked
in the longer term we feel I feel
certainly that globalization in the
economic sense will be stable and
sustainable in the longer term only if
it is accompanied by greater
democratization both within and between
countries fifthly apart from shared
values and aspirations we have long-term
intersecting interests shared interests
with the United States I referred in
this context to terrorism weapons of
mass destruction preventing the
proliferation of weapons of mass
destruction and but there are other
aspects also and this includes
the issue of energy security where if
you look at it in any longer term
perspective our interests intersect
because we have for instance a shared
interest in reducing our dependence on
fossil fuels we have a shared interest
in oil prices being stabilized at lower
levels and rate a predictability in
pricing and across the board I would say
that I do not see any area you refer to
Professor Srinivasan our differences
sometimes on one specific area like like
for instance you refer to Iraq we do not
have differences in terms of objectives
we do hope both in india and the united
states that iraq will emerge we do hope
that it will emerge as a federal
democracy like India and the United
States it will take time we know that
but we hope it will be sooner rather
than later and we hope that it will be
stable and also as a democracy and as a
prosperous democracy be a factor of
stability in that entire region so our
goals are the same but sometimes how to
achieve those goals that sometimes we
have differences of perception based
also in terms of our own historical
experiences and due to other factors but
another overriding another overriding
aspect I mean I mean aspect of
overriding importance is that our
relationship is called the relationship
between democracies and people-to-people
ties have always played an important
role and this has been even before we
became free and even after our freedom
we've had people I mean not just I refer
to the visitor prison eyes now to India
and the tremendous enthusiasm it
generated a tremendous goodwill when for
the United States was demonstrated at
that time and which incidentally still
exists we in fact if you go across there
might be some differences in terms of
some policies but if you ask an average
Indian anywhere in any part of India and
the extent of goodwill for the united
states i would say exceeds that in any
other asian country certainly apart from
the philippines and much more than many
of the places where i've served
including germany and in high Kingdom
and this is you know and this has been
manifested in these people to people
contacts between let's say I remember
the visit of dr. Martin Luther King jr.
to India when he visited India and I was
among one of those impromptu all the
audience's you know which there was no I
mean he didn't come as a he was not a
head of government but the crowds were
enthusiastic he had come both of them
had come as my guests personal guests of
prime minister nehru but it was a there
was tremendous enthusiasm in those
in the crowds which greeted him wherever
he went and I remember what he had said
in response to a question somebody asked
him how his visit was going and he said
he told that person who happened to be a
college student like myself at that time
and he said young man I have not come
here on wizard I've come here on a
pilgrimage to land or Gandhi so these
people to people contacts also the work
done by people I professor Norman
Borlaug and mms swaminathan these are
important and they will remain important
in future and in this context i would
like to say that i would like to pay a
tribute to the role of the indian
american community as a major force for
both promoting this relationship and
acting acting as a stabilizing factor in
this relationship i would conclude by
saying that it's the relationship is
never as good it has been said before
but I'll repeat it it's never as good at
it as it is today and it's getting
better all the time but it's still and
premature to say that it can be put on
autopilot let you know it has reached it
has not yet reached a critical mass
where it can carry on on its own it is
coming close but it's not reached that
point it will still need to be nurtured
and we will have to build more political
consensus in both countries the
political the kind of political
consensus which is manifested for
instance in the United States during the
wart on the civil nuclear legislation
but overall due to factors which I
mentioned and more I am confident that
this relationship is set to firmly set
on an upward trajectory thank you very
much for giving me such a patient
listening I've talked much longer than I
should have but as pristine Emerson said
that I would really welcome
questions I would also have welcome
actually some comments and criticism or
advice whatever you might whatever you
might put it at benefit from that thank
you address which is a tour de force of
the relationship between India and the
United States and its evolution I'm sure
there are lots of questions in your mind
please LAN up behind the microphone to
the corridor and Tessie
I do have a question I was particularly
glad to hear you single out of education
where we can help common future there's
one aspect that you split over that's
gonna sore point on this side of the
ocean
the Government of India might address
those things or whether this is just a
problem that's going to restrict us in
the future I think it's a very valid
point you made the desi I I think what's
happening is quite a present policy to
put it very frankly is it's stupid it's
self-defeating and this is going to be
addressed and we should actually be
doing much more we should be
facilitating not coming in the way and
one of the problems Jay face very
frankly is you know is that we do not
have we'll have to do some will have to
carry some education reforms within our
own country because there's a lot of
goodwill there's a willingness I find
from from a number of you know people in
number of universities which I visited I
have specific proposals but a big part
of the problem is the way it is
constituted right now in India it's
complex i know it's complex because
education as you know is a state subject
but there's some central some areas
where the central government also is
involved but largely a state subject but
in between you know it constantly
falling in between two stools and it's a
bit of a mess i think we can begin to a
lot and clearing that up and the least
we can do and I hope this problem
particularly relating to Fulbright
scholarships and number of those
problems I hope that in the coming a
couple of months they'll be rizal result
thank you for bringing it to my
attention
thank you very much that was very
illuminating could you say a word about
the status of discussions between India
Israel and the United States about the
purchase of the arrow defense system
please if you feel free to share some
information about that right now I don't
think that there are any that you know
it's not one system we are looking at i
think we're looking at there are certain
options which we have which we are
exploring and also in terms of our own
indigenous programs we have some areas
where which i know that we were pursuing
some collaborations also to provide some
inputs so it's not just procurement of a
system that it's also involving some
collaboration because we have certain
strengths which we have developed on our
own but i would like to say that you
refer to israel we the relations between
India and Israel have developed very
very rapidly and in Israel is our second
largest factor and partner in terms of
defense cooperation and the relationship
is in the area defense particularly is
base epic since its involves
predictability and trust on a long-term
basis is one which has taken all very
well and that is a reflection of the
long-term trust and confidence on the
part of both the partners as they are
Israel and India in this relationship
we have not reached that stage I yet
with the United States but our intention
is to get there and to get there as soon
as possible we will have to overcome
some problems because in this area and
in certain other areas so far the United
States has been used to dealing with
allies treaty allies and or with the
dual series I don't think you have many
major vessels adversary's at the moment
but it's not so we'll have to it will
have to be a very specific type of
relationship which you build up with
India which is not going to be an ally
in a traditional sense because we it's
too vibrant to democracy and to logic
democracy and to diverse a democracy to
be follower of any country and will not
be so it will we'll have to work out
some mechanisms which I which are not
yet in place to enable cooperation in
the field of defense to develop as both
our countries desire so we are in
process of getting there in fact next
month I will be commissioning and the
first u.s. origin naval vessel into the
Indian Navy at Norfolk in Virginia thank
you my name is subrata chakravarthy I'm
a journalist with regard to the u.s.
Indian nuclear agreement the Communist
Party which is a key ally of the
Congress in the Lok Sabha has condemned
this agreement as a betrayal of
principle and
strategic threat to to India and they
have even discussed voting against the
government in a motion of confidence in
the parliament which the government
would then surely lose in if that this
agreement now dies what does that do to
the future of us-india relationship it's
a it's not just I won't say it's the
Communist Party of India or the
Communist Party of india-marxist or the
Communist Party of India or some of the
leftist supporters of the governing
coalition but there are others also who
have opposed the civil nuclear agreement
who expressed reservations and in any
democracy dissent is an essential
element and and the scent is a part of
any debate and discourse that we have in
our country there have been some changes
also in there's been some evolution in
the thinking of some of these parties on
the same parties which had for instance
strongly opposed the nuclear tests of
1998 their positions have evolved and
they're now becoming defenders of the
strategic program nuclear program in
India so similarly I hope that when
perception and reality come closer to
each other and it takes some time in on
any issue because as I said the
development of our relationship has been
very rapid and some people have been
taken off balance there it takes some
time for perception and reality to
intersect
but I do hope that that process will
take place and people will realize and
there's a lot of people over here a lot
of people over here in the United States
also who have doubts about this
agreement and same as we have in India
but ultimately people will realize what
Professor sreenivasan said that this is
going to is something which is going to
be of mutual benefit and it's also will
meet our shared goal of promoting
nonproliferation because if you look at
our actual track record it's the with
second to none i would say in fact it's
better than many very frank ting many
countries which are presently in the
Nuclear Suppliers group so this is an
ongoing process and I won't come to you
know the type of conclusions I don't
think we'd have any situation as
envisage by you it's not even
hypothetically at the moment thank you
thank you I'm a biology graduate student
here I implore your excellency not to
dismiss me as another una dos
anti-globalization critic for I've been
you know enjoy the benefits of
globalization as everyone and audience
but I honestly believe that a
globalization of free trade should come
at the globalization of human rights and
more importantly a respect for that so I
would be greatly obliged if your
excellency could explain for the benefit
of the audience why should us invest in
special economic zones in India and how
the Indian government plans to ensure
the rights the life and the livelihood
of poor farmers whose not trampled in
the clan grab to grab their prime
agricultural land established SCC's
given that in recent days eleven people
have been killed and 17 jor in violence
in west bengal a communist party of
india rules west bengal and even they
haven't shown restraint and recently
Union Minister come and lock has
announced that he can allow private
developer stuck where about 5,000
hectares of land so what will prevent
them
greedily grabbing land and getting away
with it so how would you explain this
thank you well I'd say that this issue
the specific issue on special economic
zones is is being debated in India
within our country as you very well know
there's been a lot of public discourse
on the subject lot of disagreements and
but across the board there has been it
is a very sad event what took place in
nandigram the police firings which in
which some innocent people lost their
lives because they were protesting and
and everyone has a right to protest and
but I can assure you that a decision
whatever decision will be taken will be
a balanced one we will have to
inevitably move to as we industrialize
we will require more land to build
manufacturing plants or or laboratories
or land to build more institutions of
higher learning or universities and so
on so forth I mean that's inevitable
that's going to happen so it's not
necessarily going to be and at the same
time to make agricultural land usage
with better education better inputs
higher technology inputs to make them
more productive to reduce losses and
that's a better way of handling this
issue so we have to get the balance
right and in India we cannot decide
these issues and banned by decree or
central or state government Fiat but
at the moment the group of ministers is
looking into this issue and a decision
which should be taken I'm sure which
will take into account the legitimate
changes or farmers who constitute you
know sixty percent plus of our
population sixty-five percent are
dependent off of operation dependent on
agriculture and we cannot no politician
or any any any one nobody in any public
position can ignore this fact and though
the proportion of Agriculture's it in
terms of our gdp is being declining even
in as early as the eighties it was
something like about forty percent and
now it's about eighteen percent of our
gdp is going to decline even though I
hope agriculture will pick up much
faster but digital decline as a
proportion of our gdp but these
interests will be taken into account
Thank You mr. ambassador I'd like to
come back to the topic of the us-india
civil nuclear agreement can you bring us
up to date on the state of play of the
123 agreement and as you know the first
phase was a pretty hard slog getting it
through the house and the Senate in this
country we are picking up sounds that
this 123 agreement is going to be even
tougher particularly with the elections
coming up can you tell us how you see
this playing out over here I yes I have
heard a lot of speculation has been some
sense of frustration which has been
conveyed I think including in briefing
people in the media and congressional
staffers and congressmen all that I can
say is that it is not necessarily
true but it is not our policy to comment
on negotiations in progress because we
would not like to carry out these
discussions in public so it is very
tempting for me to do so because I can
refute many of the things which are
being put out but it's it's I don't
think it'll serve any purpose because
I'm not here and it's not my intention
to score in debating points because we
take this seriously and we hope it is
certainly difficult and what I said
earlier that is you know the strong
feelings in India strong views in India
a number of them who are against this
agreement there are strong views which
are held here but I do believe that this
agreement when the last lap is always
the most difficult and we have just
completed two stages or and have to
complete three more stages before we
finalize this agreement and I am not
pessimistic but to stay at that dance
current stage of negotiations I would
not like to comment on any detail
forgive me thank you you did mention
India Indian investment abroad now
exceed for an investment coming into
India now on one hand the Indian
investment increase is due to the fact
our private corporate sector is not very
dynamic and they're acquiring companies
abroad the chorus steel example the
aluminum example and so on on the other
side it seems to be our domestic
investment climate is abysmal in the
world bank's ranking of countries of the
on doing business India ranks 135 among
170 or so hundred fifty or so countries
and with respect to many things how much
how long it takes to start a business
how long it takes to close down a
business of 8 a-4 doesn't function and
the whole host of clearances and so on
and so forth and that is what is keeping
foreign investment coming to coming to
India and also domestic investment
increasing much further than it has now
what is your assessment of where we are
going with respect to creating a much
more welcoming investment climate that
would along the line from infrastructure
to bureaucracy to
professor I think that first I would
like to say about the investment climate
you know in in in India and as you
rightly put it it's we can and we should
be doing much more when I was in Germany
I used to hear these questions all the
time and so I but it didn't quite
correspond to what I even I talked to
see you or some number of companies
large companies small companies the
middle stunt has been on Germany or even
the smaller companies so I had requested
the the Federation of German chambers of
commerce and industry just to do a study
not of analysis in a 15-year perspective
of profitability for instance what is
the net profitability of companies large
medium small companies German companies
because this is a matter of record no
analysis net profitability over 15 year
period and they took to other countries
China and Indonesia Indonesia at that
time was much I mean listen let's put it
was more stable and predictable and one
was that fact that's net profitability
second was how much in terms of how much
of volatile was a volatile with it blow
up a town or was it more or less stable
in terms of profitability the third
factor was the percentage of companies
which started business and then they had
folder business both in terms of number
of companies and terms of value another
factor was time taken from initial
investment to profitability and some of
the answers I knew
that didn't surprise me and this was
during that the height of this is
15-year perspective that means including
a period where you are at the height of
the license what do you call this
license per meter Raj in India but we
came ahead in all these criteria
factually so that was very illustrative
because but people unfortunately i might
mention this but people do not do not
invest on the basis of facts they go on
base of perception and there's a certain
herd instinct and when you reach a
certain critical mass people ask a
question not whether i should invest in
X or Y country but can I afford not to
be there in some other countries like if
you take China for instance much of this
initial that critical mass was built up
by overseas Chinese investments
constitute about seventy percent then
you as you know it grew and that had a
gravitational pull of its own in India
it's going to take a longer for this
this reality is also to percolate and
each one of the and and so we can as I
said having said all of this I think we
can do much more and we are doing its
stage by stage if you look at it it's
not in my view my personal view I think
we can and could have gone faster but
even then if you like for instance
there's people are talking about you
know we have reached a sort of we have
lost the momentum has been lost nothing
is happening there is a great
disappointment but the fact is that even
if you take just the last in two or
three years it's the three years so if
you look at import duties we had it as
you know professor it was about twenty
and twenty nine percent now it's ten
percent I mean in non-agricultural where
is the peak trap rate the applied rate
has been actually about something like
about 66 on opposite across the ball
now so we without doing anything
dramatic the fact is that we have been
able to bring down this was one of the
problem areas you spoke about
infrastructure it's a lot of people
didn't realize you know that in India
actually even at the height of the
Narrows you know the position on the
commanding heights of the public sector
actually the as you know professor the
private sector played a much bigger role
in a country like India as compared to
countries like Germany or France even
when talking privatization you refer to
telephones telephone privatization began
in the same year in India and Germany
the Telecom Regulatory Authority Wilson
but we have completed the process
Germany is still in the stage of doing
so its deutsche telekom has not been
fully prioritized and what was
considered you refer to infrastructure
it's I honestly believe that you know
today's problem can be tomorrow's
opportunity there again I take telecom
it was a huge concern it the people were
complaining all the time how can you do
business you talk of information
technology how do you conduct business
without work a telephone working today
it is seen as a fastest growing telecom
market the huge opportunity we can
convert every such challenge into an
opportunity but the biggest challenge
where we will face a problem because for
geographical location because of the
certain should I say some some degrees
of uncertainty in our immediate
neighborhood one problem which we will
not be able to resolve just by issues on
issues of policy then that is going to
be energy because we are cut off from
energy sources because of where we are
located geographically
and we will have to diversify these
sources and we'll have to do much more
but we I agree with you we have to do
much more like for instance without
going into much greater detail I mean we
will not be able to we will have to
generate more in terms of investments we
have done we are not done that badly
there are great inefficiencies I think
we can make reduce transaction costs in
India but if you really look at it for
instance with you know what our savings
rate is quite high it's around thirty
percent allah with over thirty percent
but it's not just in china which is
about forty percent but we are
investments into india is one-tenth of
china so savings rate is much lower
investment rate is much lower our
exports or a fraction of china but
nonetheless the difference in terms of
GDP growth is about two or three percent
so something we must be doing right in
our own confused manner no but we could
do better thank you thank you very much
you